Giavanna usually takes Busbee to work
but now she thinks that bus a gets her
to work faster she randomized 50
workdays between a treatment group and a
control group for each day from the
treatment group she took bus a and for
each day from the control group she took
Busbee each day she timed the length of
her drive and though this is really
interesting what she did is very
important she randomized the 50 workdays
support she did this instead of just
kind of waking up in the morning and
just deciding on her own which bus to
take because humans are infamously bad
at being random even when we think we're
being random we're actually not that
random she might inadvertently be taking
bus a earlier in the week where maybe
the the commute times are shorter or
maybe she inadvertently takes bus a when
when the weather is better when there's
less traffic and remember she you know
there's a natural tendency for human
beings to want to confirm their
hypothesis so if she thinks that bus a
is faster maybe she'll want to pick the
days where it will she'll get data to
confirm her hypothesis so it's really
important that she randomized the 50
workdays and so what I could imagine she
did is maybe she wrote each of the work
day the dates on a piece of paper so she
would have 50 pieces of paper and then
she turned them all upside down and or
maybe she closed her eyes and then she
moved them all over her table and then
with her eyes closed she randomly moved
them to either the left or the right of
the table and if they moved to the left
of the table then those of the days
she'll take plus a if she moves up to
the right of the table those the day she
takes bus B and that's how she can make
sure that this is truly random all right
so then they tell us the results this is
important the results of the experiment
show that the median travel duration for
bus a is 8 minutes less than the median
travel duration for bus B or one way to
think about it if we said if we said the
treatment treatment group the treatment
group median minus minus the control
group median control group median what
would we get well the treatment group is
8 minutes less than the control group
right this is a this is B so if this is
8 less than this then this is going to
be equal to negative 8 this is just
another way of reached
eating what I have underlined right over
here someone's car alarm went off hope
your you're not hearing that anyway I'll
try to pay attention while it's going
off to test whether the results could be
explained by random chance she created
the table below which summarizes the
results of 1,000 reran demise ations of
the data with differences between
medians rounded to the nearest 5 minutes
so what is going on over here you might
say well look she got her result that
she wanted to get she sees this data
seems to confirm that bus a gets her to
work faster what's all this other
business with rhe randomization she's
doing well the important thing to
realize is and she realizes this is that
she might have just gotten this data
that I underlined by random chance
there's some chance maybe a and B are
completely similar in terms of how long
they take in reality and she just
happened to pick bus a on days that are
where bus a got to work faster maybe
busing B is faster but she just happened
to take bus a on the days that it was
faster the days that just happened to
have less traffic so what she's doing
here is shiri randomized the data and
she wants to see what what if with all
this reran demise data out of these
1,000 re randomizations what fraction of
them do I get a result like this do I
get a result where a is 8 minutes or
more faster I guess you or you could say
that the median travel duration for bus
a is 8 minutes less or even less than
that then the median travel for bus B so
if it was 9 minutes less or 10 minutes
less or 15 minutes less those are all
the interesting ones those are the ones
that confirm our hypothesis that bus a
gets to work faster so let's look at
this table it's not below it's actually
to the right so let's just let's just
remind ourselves what she did here
because the first time you you try to
process this it can seem a little bit
daunting so in a her experiment let me
write this down
experiment the car alarm outside which
you probably hopefully are not hearing
it's actually a surprisingly pleasant
sounding car alarm sounds like a like a
slightly obnoxious bird but anyway so
her experiment is so the way I described
it 25 days she would take bus a 25 days
she took a bus B and she would record
all the travel times and let's say that
I just have 25 data points
each column and so let's say they get 12
minutes 20 minutes 25 minutes and you
just keep going there's 25 data points
and let's just say that there are 12
data points less than 20 minutes and 12
data points more than 20 minutes and so
in this circumstance or median time for
bus a would be 20 minutes and I just
made this number up and so in order for
this to be 8 minutes less than the
median time for bus B the median for bus
B maybe we would have to be 28 and maybe
you have data points here maybe this is
18 and you have 12 more that are less
than 28 and then you have 12 12 more
that are greater than 28 and so the
median time for bus B the median time
for bus B would be 28 once again I just
made this data up and if you took
contribute median and I'll just write
I'll write TGM for short T gm- control
group median control group median what
do you get 20 - 20 8 is negative 8 this
is this is the actual results of or
these are theoretical or potential
results hypothetical results for her
actual experiment now what's all of this
business over here well what she did is
she took these times and she said you
know what maybe let's just imagine a
world where I could have gotten any of
these times randomly on either bus so
she just randomly Reese ordered them
between she just randomly Reese ordered
them between a and B and she did that a
thousand times
so the first time the second time the
third time and she does this she does
this one thousand one thousand times I'm
assuming she's some type of a computer
program to do it and each time once
again she she just took the data that
she had and she just rearranged it she
just she just reshuffled it so maybe a
on one day maybe it gets maybe it gets
this maybe it got this 18 maybe it gets
the 25 maybe gets a 30 once again so got
the 18 the 25 of the 30 and maybe B gets
the and you know she's reshuffling all
this other data points that I just have
with dots and maybe B let's see
she had the 18 25 30 maybe 12 20 28 12
20 and 28 and so in this circumstance
this random reshuffling and she keeps
doing it over and over again in this
random reshuffling the treatment group
median minus the control group median is
going to be what it's going to be equal
to positive five in this random
shuffling this hypothetical scenario bus
A's median would have been five minutes
more longer than bus B's and so if she
gets this result with this random Reese
orden this would have been and this is
actually a this is a she would have had
a column here four or five and then she
would have she would have notched put
one notch right over here but it looks
like she she classified things or maybe
she didn't even get the data but she
classified them by multiples of two but
then if she got this again then she
would have put a two here and then she
should have said okay and how many of
these random reshuffling x' am I getting
a scenario where there is a a
five-minute difference so or where the
treatment group is five minutes longer
so what is this so what is this saying
so for example for example this is
saying that 18 out of the a thousand
reshuffling x' which she just randomly
reshuffled the data 18 out of those
thousand times
she found a scenario where her treatment
group median was ten minutes longer than
her control group where bus Ayotte is
median was this hypothetical rear and
emission where the treatment group is
ten minutes slower than the control
group there were 159 times where the
treatment group once again in her random
reshuffling they see these aren't based
on observations these are random reefs
off shufflings there's a hundred and
fifty-nine times where her treatment
group is four minutes slower than her
control group so the whole reason for
doing this is she says okay what's the
probability of getting a result like
this like this or better and I say
better is you know I guess one that even
more confirms our hypothesis that the
treatment group is faster than the
control group
well the scenario this scenario is this
one right over here and then another one
that where the treatment group is
this is even faster is this right over
here here the treatment group median is
10 less is 10 less than the control
group median so how many and how many of
these scenarios out of the thousand is
this occurring well this one occurs 85
times this one occurs 8 so if you add
these two together 93 out of the
thousand times out of Harare
randomization or I guess you could say
9.3 percent of the time if the data if
you night at nine point three percent of
the randomized of the in the 1000 year
and emissions nine point three percent
of the time she got data that was as as
validating of hypothesis or more than
the actual experiment so one way to
think about this is the probability of
randomly getting the results from her
experiment are or or better results from
her experiment are nine point three
percent so they're low it's a reasonably
low probability that that this happened
purely by chance now a question is is
well what's the threshold if it was a 50
percent you say okay this was you know
very likely to happen by chance if this
was a 25 percent you're like okay it's
it's less likely to happen by chance but
it could happen
9.3 percent its roughly 10 percent you
know every for every 10 people who do a
an experiment like she did one person
with even if it was random one person
would get data like this so what
typically happens among statisticians is
they draw threshold and the threshold
for statistical significance is usually
five percent so one way to think about
the probability of her getting this
result by chance or this result or a
more extreme result one that more
confirms our hypothesis by chance is
nine point three percent now if your if
your cutoff for significance is five
percent if you said okay this has to be
five percent or less then you say okay
this is not statistically significant
there's a more than a five percent
chance that I could have gotten this
result purely through random chance now
once again that's just depends on where
you have that threshold so when we go
back I think we've already answered the
final question according to the
simulations what is the probability of
the treatment groups median being lower
than the control groups media
in by eight minutes or more which once
again eight minutes or more that would
be negative eight and negative ten and
we just figured that out that was 93 out
of the thousand re randomizations so
it's a 9.3 percent chance and if you set
5% as your cutoff for statistical
significance you'd say okay this doesn't
quite meet my my my cutoff so I made
maybe this is not a statistically
significant result